[Music]
and they say the Justinian's mother
stated to some of her intimates that he
was not the son of her husband Sabathia
s' nor of any man for when she was about
to conceive him a demon visited her he
was invisible but affected her with a
certain impression that he was there
with her as a man having intercourse
with a woman and then disappeared as in
a dream and some of those who were
present with the Emperor at very late
hours of the night presumably and held
conference with him obviously in the
palace men whose souls were pure seemed
to see a sort of phantom spirit
unfamiliar to them in place of him for
one of these asserted that he would rise
suddenly from the imperial throne and
walk up and down there indeed he was
never accustomed to remain seated for
long and the head of Justinian would
disappear suddenly but the rest of his
body
seemed to keep making these sane long
circuits while he himself as if thinking
he must have something the matter with
his eyesight stood there for a very long
time
distressed and perplexed later however
when the head had returned to the body
he thought to his surprise that he could
fill out that which a moment before had
been lacking and another person said
that he stood beside him while he sat
and suddenly saw that his face had
become like featureless flesh for
neither eyebrows nor eyes were in their
proper place nor did it show any other
means of identification whatsoever after
a time however he saw the features of
his face returned
[Music]
these things I write although I did not
see them myself but I do so because I
have heard the story from those who
declared that they saw the occurrences
at the time and they said that a certain
monk very dear to God
being persuaded by those who lived with
him in the wilderness set out to
Byzantium in order to plead the cause of
the people who lived a very near the
monastery and were being mistreated and
wronged in an unbearable manner and
straightaway upon his arrival he
received admittance to the Emperor but
while he was about to go into his
presence he stepped over the threshold
with one foot but suddenly recoiled and
stepped back now the eunuch who was his
conductor and the others present
besought the man earnestly to go forward
but he making no answer but acting like
a man who had suffered a stroke departed
thence and went to the room where he was
lodged and when his attendants inquired
for what reason he acted thus they said
that he declared outright that he had
seen the Lord of the demons in the
palace sitting on the throne and he
would not care to associate with him or
ask anything from him and how could this
man fail to be some wicked demon he who
had never had a sufficiency of food or
drink or sleep but taking a taste at
haphazard of that which was set before
him walked about the palace at
unreasonable hours of the night though
he was passionately devoted to the joys
of Aphrodite and some of the lovers of
Theodora say that when she was on the
stage some sort of demon descended upon
them a night and drove them from the
room in which they were spending the
night with her and there was a there was
a dancing girl Macedonia by name
belonging to the blue faction Antioch a
woman who would acquire great influence
for by writing letters to Justinian
while he was still administering the
Empire for just eNOS she without
difficulty kept destroying whomsoever
she wished
among the notable men of the
and causing their property to be
confiscated to the Treasury they say
that once this Macedonia when greeting
Theodora as she came from Egypt and
Libya noticed that she was very
distressed and vexed over the
high-handed treatment to which she'd
been subjected by hecka bolus and also
because she lost some money on the
journey and so she comforted her greatly
and encouraged her by suggesting that
fortune was quite able to become once
again for her a purveyor of great wealth
on that occasion they said Theodora
remarked that in fact a dream had come
to her during the night just passed and
had bidden her to lay aside all anxiety
as far as wealth was concerned for as
soon as she would come to Byzantium she
would lie with the Lord of demons and
were quite certainly lived there with
him as his married wife and he would
cause her to be mistress of money
without limit
[Music]